Since the amount of steps
can vary widely based on
the specific implementations,
we normally use approximations
when talking about efficiency
in big O notation.
Since the efficiency of
the pseudo code we wrote before
could end up looking like
any of these and even more,
we would say that the efficiency
is actually about O(n).
If you're writing code for production
you definitely care about the number of
computations and want to minimize it.
However, in an interview, your
interviewer doesn't care that you can do
that exactly, but just wants to know
that you are thinking about efficiency
and can calculate it if you need to.
By approximating, we're really saying
some number of computations must be
performed for each letter in the input.
There's actually more things you should
consider when using big O notation.
If you noticed before I said
you'll need at least 26 checks to
get through every
letter of the alphabet.
In reality it's unlikely that you'll
have to go through all 26 letters
each time.
When we're discussing efficiency
we often talk about it in terms of
the worst case scenario, where we would
have to check all 26 letters each time.
We focus on worst case because it puts
an upper bound on the amount of time our
code is going to take.
You could also talk about efficiency
in terms of the average case or
even best case.
So if we're talking about
letters in the alphabet,
the worst case means we would have
to go through all 26 letters.
However the best case would be that
we find what we're looking for
on the very first try, but on average,
we're going to fall somewhere
in the middle, around 13.
In a perfect world,
iterating through a list of letters is
going to take an average of 13 times.
Sometimes it will be a little more,
sometimes it will be a little less, but
it's fair to say it will be about 13.
If we're going to try and
calculate the average case efficiency,
it's going to look a little more like
this, in the end will get 16n+2.
Now let's go back to our
point about approximations.
If we consider the average
case the worst case or
the best case,
it's also going to result in O(n).
In an interview you might be tempted
to combine the average case,
the worst case, the best case, and
just give an answer like this.
However the best case,
the worst case, and
the average case might not
always approximate this nicely.
So you really should specify
to your interviewer which case
you're talking about.
We've been talking a lot
about time efficiency but
you can actually use the same notation
to refer to space efficiency too.
For example, let's say you needed
to copy over your input string
three times in your code for
some reason.
Then the space efficiency would
look something like this.
Space efficiency is asked less
frequently in interviews, but
it's definitely something you should
consider because it will come up
from time to time.